Cory Feldman's coming in how are you
doing man we were just trying to make
sure that our producer looked impressive
so he didn't make us look like fools
nobody not your headphones on the floor
yeah well do I need them if you want am
i mean we're not taking call oh my god
it sounds like 3d now that's so cool now
you're here with us
well welcome Cory I'm glad that you're
here
glad to be here I was watching I do have
a picture of Stannis upon use well we
were just our guys were at Comic Con and
they got to meet some of the superheroes
I see and so we were looking at their
meaning exactly nice of Josh to dress up
in that make up and walk around
comic-con all day that's actually a
better costume than the spider-man who
we just watched which Spiderman was made
awful yeah well you know at least you
don't live in Hollywood because in
Hollywood they have these guys that
dress up as superheroes and they stand
outside the Chinese Theater and try to
swindle money off of people they started
doing that in Times Square like you guys
that was only in Hollywood for the
longest time yeah and then bootleg Elmo
and and they're grabbing girls asses all
charges I know as I was like walking my
kid he was like four or five years old
and this guy like drops out of like a
scaffolding and like he like goes down
and picks up my kid and lifts him up
into the air and I'm like what is this
and he's like I'm spider-man I'm like no
you're not you're some wacko in a
costume put my kid down you must have
had people dressed up as your characters
you must have had like people dressed up
well geez and Lost Boys every every
weekend when I go to those conventions
man right you know I did a tour this
last year which you know I don't I don't
do those types of things very often
usually only when I have a new film
coming out but this last year because I
kind of disappeared for a few years
after my last tour we you know kind of
went behind the radar and and did a lot
of underground work to make my
documentary and in the interim wasn't
making a lot of appearances so we
decided to do a comic-con tour which was
kind of a Goonies reunion slash you know
I don't know pop-culture extravaganza
and it was amazing every
where we went there would be you know
cosplay people dressed as different
characters of mine so whether it was
like a guy with like a full Ninja
Turtles costume with like a puppet hard
work do you know you're just like how do
you build this stuff are you serious -
like you know people that look nothing
like you wearing like you know a mouth
costume and their girlfriend is dressed
as staff or Andi and then you know the
kids dressed is chunk and you know
they'll brass up a whole family like
Goonies and it's it's amazing and then
you've got people dressed as the Frog
brothers right we ran into a guy dressed
as Ricky Butler from the burbs yeah it's
crazy
some people just dresses means some
people dress his angels you know they'll
show up in lingerie and angel wings and
stuff like oh my god do you ever recruit
for Corey's angels no no no so like if
you meet somebody at comic-con going
like I'm dressed as an angel but I can't
really become an angel if they were
really hot and they gave me a demo and
it was amazing I'm sure back in the day
when we were recruiting for angels we
might probably taking a listen but this
is you know that was five years ago
you're married now right I'm married I
mean not to say that Corey's angels
would have existed or wouldn't have
existed with the marriage certainly my
wife you know was part of it and was one
of the founders of it so she wouldn't be
opposed to it it's just more that gosh
it was it was more trouble than it was
worth to be honest with you I mean it
was there was it was great success it
was it was a thing that everybody seemed
to love at the moment but unfortunately
there was a lot of competitors who
didn't like the fact that we were so
successful so quickly and they just
basically did everything they could to
trash us both in the media and you know
I mean we would throw these events where
you know they'd be sold out in seconds
and then all of a sudden we'd have the
police banging in our door at 10 o'clock
at night saying you know you can't throw
an event here and we'd be like what is
this you know but there was just a lot
of sabotage and who were the competitors
to Corey's angels well we don't want to
really talk about that you know we don't
want to out anybody but let's just say
that the whole thing started yeah I mean
the whole thing started with my
connection to Playboy cause right
because Corey's angels became an
offshoot of that and while Hef was still
alive he was very much supportive of it
to the point where on his wedding night
with crystal the angels were sitting at
the table in front of him
and you know it was almost like this
passing of the baton sort of thing so
let's just say that around the time of
the demise of playboy there were certain
people with certain interests that were
trying to take over that company that
did not want to see it continue I see
yeah do you feel do you feel vindicated
at all because all the stuff about like
sexual predators in Hollywood and it
sounded like a quarry is just crazy and
then all of a sudden they find this tape
that you claimed existed in the life
they found it you know why they found it
they found it because I was like hey
guess what I found my copy and I'm gonna
release it and they were like Oh what do
you know he was right yeah we have it
exactly do you feel vindicated oh I know
I feel like I made them cop to something
but that doesn't mean that I feel
vindicated I'll feel vindicated when the
truth comes out and these guys go to
jail they'll feel vindicated it wasn't
last like two years I feel like every
time you would open your mouth about
sand this year it's been like I don't
know anything about corey feldman but
all this stuff he was saying yeah here's
all the evidence it was true right well
let's just say that there's a reason why
I created a movement called kids - kids
- with a capital K hashtag capital K
lowercase IDs and a - and there's a
reason for that because me - is a lovely
concept and a lovely idea but
unfortunately it just ignored the fact
that the kids are the biggest problem
the women being abused isn't the biggest
problem for the most part women are
grownups and they can take care of
themselves and they can defend
themselves unless of course they're
being attacked or raped or something
awful like that but I mean you know for
the most part they're grown humans
children do not agree to any of this
they do not make a decision to go to a
meeting in a hotel room they do not make
a decision to you know become actors for
the most part or go to auditions or
whatever it's their parents that are
driving that and they're just you know
kind of going along because their
parents tell them this is what you need
to do who are they protecting each other
because it sounded really paranoid and
conspiratorial and then you hear all
this stuff about well no this guy was
protecting that guy and it's like it
starts first of all we made a
documentary for this very reason and the
documentary is
pretty much finished but we're still
looking for distributors so anybody
listening if you happen to have the
power or the company or the ability to
distribute our film come talk to me
because we need distribution but the
point being that in our film we document
the fact that this is not just my story
this is not just Corey Haims story this
is the story of hundreds of kids who've
been through the entertainment industry
over the decades and it's not just the
story of their story but it's also about
the systemic abuse and the approach to
covering it up and how that works and
how it happens so we go through the
whole history we show you exactly how it
works because there's certain codes like
key words that are used between the
lower-level people in the industry that
help cover all this stuff up and the way
they do that is just it's like a simple
looking the other way thing where
they're like oh you know there's this
guy that's on the set that you probably
don't want to work with or you probably
don't want to like have you know your
kid hang around with because like we've
heard he's kind of creepy and they'll
tell you that right walk on a set well
my question is why is the guy on the set
if I know he's creepy why does he still
have the job by the way my fame we've
heard that he's kind of creepy is code
sure that's right and then when you know
when something happens or maybe it
doesn't happen with him but maybe it
happens with one of his friends who
comes to hang out with the kid because
that guy seems totally normal so he
introduces you the other friend or
whatever it is but then it gets to be a
manager or an agent or a publicist or
somebody that's really close you know
but not top level I mean that's all
thing everybody's like well it's these
executives no it's actually all the
people on the bottom level that get away
with murder and the reason they get away
with murder whether it's a first
assistant director or a director or you
know small-time producer or whatever it
is it's because the production company
says to people like yes if there's a
problem we definitely want you to report
it we got to do the right thing and so
you know the kid goes you know or the
mom or whatever goes okay well then
we're gonna do the right thing and they
say yeah call your agent and file a
report with the Union filed a report
with sag we don't do it here on the set
but you call your agent and you deal
with it and they're like okay we will
and so they call their agent and they
get all intents and they're like yeah we
need help with this this is terrible and
the agent says oh you're right that
sounds terrible I'll tell you what
we're gonna make sure that we take care
of this right away but just so you know
once we start the process and we're
gonna have to call the police because
we're gonna have to file a report
because that's the only way this works
and then we have to report it to the
Union once these reports are made you
know there will be investigations and we
will get to the bottom of it and
hopefully we can get you some justice
but again just you understand once that
happens well the show's gonna get shut
down because obviously once a complaint
is filed they're gonna start looking at
us then everybody's gonna have to take a
hideous possibly the show will get shut
down permanently and then everybody no
longer has a job and then you know
they're all gonna kind of look at you
and go well yeah the reason nobody has a
job is because this kid complained right
so this kid's gonna get blacklisted and
this kid's never gonna work again so do
you want to be responsible for causing
all of these people their jobs now
nobody's got a place to go to work now
nobody's got anywhere to go and it's all
your fault but hey well the agents are
somehow again it's never actually said
right there somehow tight did-did
leaving Neverland present like a real
dilemma for you because here's Michael
Jackson I'd rather not talk about that
okay yeah I've already said what I have
to say on the subject and I'd rather
stay away from the whole Michael Jackson
topic if possible it was it wasn't even
really about him other than when you
look at other people who are whether
they're his or anybody else's perceived
victims is it hard for you to not listen
to somebody when they say hey this
happened I have to listen to somebody
because I'm the ambassador for child USA
so my point and my purpose is to take
every single abuse claim seriously now
does that mean that they're all true not
all true but when it comes to childhood
sexual abuse
90% of claims are true so therefore we
have to take it very seriously and yes
there are cases where people go after
the money and it's not necessarily true
but those cases generally come from
adults who are claiming stuff that
happened when they were younger
not in cases where kids start talking
about it in early age you heard me
talking about it at 18 okay I went to
the police now I was a rare exception
because at the end of the day most
people are not comfortable dealing with
it until they're much older and much
later in life
in their 50s in their 60s that that you
know is the general that's why the
statute of limitations was always set at
such a young age because they knew that
people were gonna be able to deal with
it until much later in life okay so at
55 that's when male adults finally come
to terms with the fact like hey that
wasn't okay with me that emotionally
scarred me maybe that's why my marriages
haven't been working out maybe that's
why I've been an abusive father maybe
that's why ba bla bla bla bla bla bla
because they've suddenly realized that
they hate themselves or they hate the
people that did this to them but it's
too late because you can't get their
appeal or something when you're an old
dog right you can get therapy for
something when you're young enough to
actually change it so the point is is
that what we're doing like in New York
we passed the CVA with the help of child
USA and what that did was that allowed
for the first time in New York there to
be a 1 year look-back window to open old
cases and it also put forth a longer
statute of limitations in the state of
New York so we had to go fight for that
in Albany we got it passed this year it
changed in January and that's why you
saw indictments for our Kelly and
Jeffrey Epstein in the first place that
you're fighting this this is it the
church I know the churches for certain
statute of limitations they're afraid it
will bang of course do you know how much
the church's insurance people spend
every year on child molestation cases
they spent they have insurance people
that go out there and they protect them
and they spend I think it's like 70
million a year on insurance just on
insurance just on the cream on the basic
coverage right to make sure that their
priests get to stay employed and move
from pasture to pasture from that's when
you know that there's a lot of damage
that's 70 million dollars in insurance
is cheaper than actually pay right all
being the plan all states do you going
from how do you ask Allstate for
insurance and sexual yeah kids it exists
that's the scary thing it exists so it
actually benefits them to have the
sexual assault because otherwise nobody
would get paid do you think in in in
guess why they move them around that's
why they don't just handle it right it's
just frustrating do you think the fact
and we won't get into Michael but my
question is about you and the fact that
you know you've been really public about
I
great friends with Michael and there was
nothing to the accusations in my case do
you think that that's complicated
because those accusations about Michael
have been around for as long as they've
been around do you think that that
becomes a complication when you're
trying to get your message across I
thought this wasn't about Michael that
seems a little bit of a sidewind it kind
of you know the topic no and that speak
Ned's been such a prevalent know part of
the conversation for now the only
problem is I can't go and question the
people that I would normally probably
question pretty hard if it doesn't feel
right to me because of the fact that I'm
the ambassador for child II was it
because I can't go and say well right
okay guys definitely can't be telling
the truth that's not right because then
I would be just as tone-deaf as the rest
of the people that are ignoring
everything that I'm saying and everybody
else is saying can we all have to listen
well that's the point you are a guy who
is dealt with it like you've had it
happen
so as it what is something and I know
it's different with different people
because everyone's kind of an individual
but if you're listening to any person
talk about say sexual abuse what is
something that was set off the alarm
bells in your head to go
that doesn't sound truthful or anything
like yeah like what is something that as
a person yeah you know look again I'm
not here to try and question why
somebody wouldn't be telling the truth
I'm not here to question how that
doesn't sound truthful I'm here to say
if this sounds like injustice we need to
find justice that's my job my job is to
find the path for them to deal with
their case and if if you know they find
lawyers and they report their stuff to
the police and there's a thorough
investigation and it turns out not to be
provable well then so be it it turned
out not to be provable but at least they
should have their shot they should have
their chance that's all I'm saying what
every voice should be heard what did you
think when you found out that Jeffrey
Epstein had committed suicide in jail he
did not commit suicide right I don't I
really don't think you saw that his life
was over any any did you realize that he
had just met with his lawyer that day
and they had just gone through an entire
plan how he was going to make a deal
again like the deal he made the last
time that got him out I
I know I'm for me what convinced me that
he did it was the fact that he he people
he wrote a will out a couple days before
and he put all his money and trust and I
think he just saw that his life was over
I mean it would it shocked me completely
if it was something else no not at all
but I just don't I just see no footage
so are you a big Trump supporter I have
mixed feelings about Trump I didn't vote
for him I don't hate him okay I think
he's right about the press he's a
hundred percent right about the press
but I think there's a lot of things that
I don't like kiss stance on gay people I
don't like your stance and a lot of
things but you know there's not a
hundred percent right about the press I
feel he is and then comes Fox all them
come on I feel that he's a whole lot you
guys realize that who says that because
he doesn't want the people to believe
anything they hear on the news because
it might be the truth and it might make
him look bad but I know I don't know is
that because I knew I'm not him no but
I'm saying you can always say like look
it's real easy to go like hey don't
believe anything you hear that bad about
me from anybody else because they're
saying it not me no anybody can do that
what I'm saying is my belief in the
press long before Trump became president
is their agenda driven oh yeah but
here's the thing okay and this is what
everybody needs to realize the
difference between fake news as he calls
it and real fake news is there is no
such thing as fake fake news when it
comes to national media when it comes to
international media when you're talking
about the major news networks like NBC
Fox CBS whatever all of them have to
base their stories in reality they have
to have a basis of reality to fact-check
against and they have to prove that
they've done ABC and D to fact-check
their stories to make them legitimate so
there has to be substance listen I'm a
guy who's been lied about a lot and it's
been completely twisted in the media so
I'm saying this from the perspective of
like I know the difference between what
fake news is and not fake well fake news
doesn't say that Martians have landed
I'll be factual yeah thank you that's my
boy not just factual human beings but
factual events that have taken place the
fake news thing wasn't started by Trump
I believe that was started by Democrats
when they were they were getting
positive news stories and that was not
started by truck start the whole fake
the first time I ever missing my point
my point is that there are certain
elements that they will make up
to to color a story in their favor or
towards their objectives so that it
sounds more something you know suitable
for their base for their audience right
whereas or if they want to get rid of a
certain celebrity or they want to shoot
somebody down then they'll all kind of
jump on them at the same time and that I
believe is guided and is directed and
there is a common goal within the media
to destroy this certain person or to
build a certain person up that's for
sure and I'll give you that yeah but
what I'm saying is they don't take it
out in nowhere they always have to have
a basis for their story and there has to
be an element of truth at the beginning
and end of each story but you you're in
a way making my point I know what you're
saying but to me it's not whether it's
about Donald Trump or whether it's about
Hillary Clinton right it's the idea that
the reason they're frauds is because
they lie about the fact that there is an
agenda that they're going on I'll give
you that they live under this umbrella
of we are impartial and we are reporting
but they are first of all a they're
creating things because they want to
report on them and be their reportage
but point of bias and they have never
admitted that like like if forget Trump
why do they never do in the story about
how are we responsible for shootings
like they do the story about how comic
books responsible how violent video
games responsible guns are all valid
point but they never do this story but
how are we as depressed partially
reporters are the party what is our
responsibility how do we make ourselves
better I don't agree with everything he
says at all but I do think about the
press I love the fact that he drives
them crazy and they do not know how to
deal with him he does he makes them nuts
but he likes to hold up the ones that
are nice to him and the thing is look at
the end of the day I agree I think it's
funny but but we're in a very serious
state of affairs right now we're just
not at a place where we have the ability
to have the room to laugh at certain
things sure we do we do I don't think so
we can't we like well well we can't
protection for animals we can't laugh at
the fact that you know children and
animals we can't laugh at the fact that
there's no protection for answer we can
we laugh at murder I mean I'm not saying
that we shouldn't be laughing at that
either when you're saving your children
when you say we take an advantage I mean
the present society
comedian Utrecht unions cannot call
somebody black fat ugly stupid I mean do
you realize what society we're living in
comedians don't have the Liberty to
really speak there okay great so what so
what that's the truth it's not my choice
but that's the way it should I don't
think it's good too much rights too much
but that's the society that we framed
ourselves in now okay I said where we
can't even joke anymore and and it sucks
but that's the way it is but that's
because things have gotten so serious
and things are at a threshold right now
of you know everything's about to
explode in our faces that's I that's
unfortunately I don't think it's about
the culture and the things that things
are serious I think that it's peoples
have gotten very used to having our own
news feeds and our own comfort zones and
we don't want things made fun of that we
don't like made fun of everybody right
self-centeredness we it's not about the
country being too serious it's about the
narcissism of individuals right exactly
and it's like well if everybody does
that then nobody gets to have fun
anymore nobody gets to laugh anymore
where's the joy in life sure but but
that said too there are you know and
again there's things that I feel like
the president should be defending
regardless of his agenda like you know
you don't take away protections for
endangered species if all of a sudden we
go and shoot all the the bald eagles
what are we gonna put up on our American
flag a severed head I mean you know
really it's gotta be some kind of
American like pride and nostalgia for
the things that we've grown up you know
respecting and honoring but don't you
think they give him no credit for end
like literally if Obama hadn't met with
Kim jong-un they'd be saying he's a
diplomat Trump meets with Kim jong-un
delegates photo-op it's like you just I
don't know I couldn't Obama I think of
Obama would've met with Kim donor and
they would have said that he's
definitely terrorist and definitely
siding with Kim jong-un so they can plot
and plan against the world come on
everybody said Muslim terror yeah yeah
but again Fox is kind of he's gonna like
about Fox Wars they acknowledge and we
all know that they are biased we know
that but they don't acknowledge it they
say they're fair and balanced I know but
celebrities not going on five
it's all the same it's all the same
right to pissing on the left the left
facing on the right and everybody just
needs to stop and listen for a minute
because guess what we're not gonna make
things better until we take what both
sides want and what both sides need and
find an even place in the middle but in
fairness you did just ask me after we
were talking about something else you're
you a trump supporter like you asked me
if I thought you mentioned Trump I
forget we were just discussing Epstein
but meanwhile it was an odd question
because Trump isn't even accused by any
of Epstein's though he was on a plane
with them many many times with him and
he's been to his home anytime but the
most of the people have said that Trump
had nothing did nothing CD they said
there's more in the Clinton yeah yeah
but there's there's also reports of like
a girl who said that Trump raped her at
one of his parties and there's like a
well drawn out oh yeah I read the entire
report where like she talks about him
like smacking her throwing her down on
the bed like detailed so all I'm saying
is don't look the other way there's
there's information on both sides and
you've got to read all of it to make
your decisions when you would know
better than anybody with all the time
you've been in Hollywood I mean my
theory has always been the most powerful
people are the ones that we don't even
know what their names are we've never
heard of that's right absolutely
absolutely most of them walk in the
shadows and he has the bottom line but
there are still very famous people that
have done some very bad things and those
are the people were trying to expose in
our documentary not all of them I mean
all I know about is what I know about
there's many other people with many
other stories and they're gonna have to
come forward on their own but the one
guy that I dunno did some terrible
things who's still out there who's very
powerful who's gotten away with murder
needs to be stopped
what does he do I notice what Sam tell
you that is it in the people why can't
you tell us because it would have me
killed that's why you mentioned him in
the documentary of course yes wait so
you mentioned him in the documentary he
possibly still abusing people right but
you won't say it publicly correct then
how is he not gonna have you killing the
documentary comes out because the point
is is once all the information is out
there and people can actually put the
pieces together and understand what
happened then the investigators can
start going after him but if they just
say a name what does that do
anything you have to give people the
background you have to give them you
have to give them the evidence and lay
out all the fact this documentary would
have the evidence to make it undeniable
so killing you would do nothing right
there but if you so even if it does kill
me it won't matter as long as the movies
out I don't care I go you're saying
where's that's right now let me get it
out for you he could silence the
documentary no evidence would come out
correct and you'd be all and it'd be
Jeffrey Epstein all over again I see
yeah I get the theory all right right
yeah I don't know I mean I'm not asking
for his name I was just saying what kind
of uh he's a producer you know like once
he's very famous I'll tell you that he's
very famous is he by he's not an actor
I'm not gonna start going down every
listen everybody comes to the
documentary when it's released and get
all the information in the facts
straight so that you understand it so
from that point on you can make your
decision on how you want to proceed in
either supporting or not supporting I
like the interview that you did with
good day New York because you went on
and you're talking about the show that
you're doing marriage boot camp family
edition which is on WE tv Friday at
10:00 p.m. but you told them you really
like they were like oh why are you doing
this show and you were like because they
gave me money to do the show and it
allowed me to find my documents right
I'm a very honest person I play games
it's like look I was struggling I had no
way to get this thing done because there
was an entire disinformation campaign
created around me by people who you at
least expect to be the ones to do it and
they created an entire conspiracy of
people who tried to destroy my life I
had death threats I had two attempts on
my life I had people coming after me
from all angles
Satanists all this crazy stuff all over
the internet yes you know about it so it
was all over and it tortured me for a
year and a half and it was very very
difficult and they drained all my
accounts they created false allegations
account me against me I had to hire
lawyers at higher security all his crap
right and it drained my account so that
I couldn't make the damn documentary so
what happened was I'm sitting there
Brokaw you're paying for lawyers right
yeah yeah and I'm like what do i do how
do I get this done now yeah so they knew
that I mean they're very smart they've
done this before and they know that if
they drain your financial resources you
can't get crap done right so anyway so
I'm sitting there going like how do I
and these people come along - okay you
want to do this show and I'm like what's
the upside and they said well the upside
is you get to heel with your brother and
you know deal with all these problems
from your past and I'm like yeah but do
I want to do that on TV like you really
do that behind the scenes like what will
pay you a bunch of money and I was like
that could help cuz then i can make this
damn documentary and get the information
out because lookit I'm the last guy that
wants to sit here sitting on this
information I don't I really don't and I
don't want to be sitting on it longer
than I have to
the only reason I'm here right now and
have peace in my heart is because the
documentaries done and people have
copies of their you need yeah so I'm
saying but if somebody shot me right now
they would still put it out like it's
gonna come out there's nothing that's
gonna stop it at this point it's just a
matter of when it's a matter of when
have you thought about doing and I like
the honesty about why you did the
marriage boot camp what about doing
something like a 60 minutes or something
like that where it almost makes you
untouchable if you come out and you say
this is such a big yeah it's like
there's a they gotta ask me I mean you
know how it works I can't sit there
knocking on their door going please do
an interview with me and take me
seriously cuz that just doesn't work but
you know hopefully somebody gets the
point and gets the balls and comes to my
side and goes yeah let's get this done
come on I mean I'm willing to put my
balls out there I'm willing to throw
everything out there and say I'm putting
my life on the line I've had to death
threats I'm not stopping why can't
somebody just hand me a damn check and
say let's get this done let's go get the
space let's get the theater space let's
get the advertising let's put it out I'm
not a studio I can't do it I can produce
it I can make it with all my own money I
can put all the information I can do the
detective work but I am NOT a studio I
cannot put it out to the world I don't
have a platter do you think it will wind
up cuz I'm not that gonna show in a
theatre I mean if it should be yeah
I'm only saying if there's powerful
people they probably have a certain
ability to stop and oh you can four-wall
them that's what my plan is what I'd
like to do I wish somebody would just go
here's the money for the budget so that
we can rent say a hundred theaters just
hundred theaters I don't need a hundred
thousand I need one hundred theaters
because once it's in 100 theaters and
everybody sees it at the same time it's
gonna spread like wildfire like r.kelly
like you know leaving Neverland whatever
people are gonna wake up on Monday
morning to go holy crap this is the guy
we got a deuce
something about this and people are
gonna get motivated and it's gonna
change does he know he's the guy yes so
he's do you think he's nervous about
this yes yeah of course he's try to have
me killed of course he's nervous about
it but on top of that there's other guys
it's not just Mike like I said I'm gonna
show the history and the lore of this
thing so people understand that this is
a systemic abuse that has been going on
for generation after generation we're
not just interviewing me and my friends
who know about our situations but we're
also interviewing Disney kids who are
coming forward with stories in this
generation we're talking about kids
before my generation in the 70s that
were being molested so we go back you
know to the beginning we show that there
this has been going on historically also
show that you know there's gonna be more
if we don't stop it now sorry has he
reached out to you at all through other
people and I'm not sure sure tried to
scare you or try to offer you never
never an offer just and never clearly
you know you're kind of like you're not
really saying anything are you okay good
well you figure if you're smart he would
offer to buy the documentary let's not
put any ideas out there do it is him
dummy company you buy it and that's what
we're so we have to vet very carefully
anybody that we deal with trying to give
them his right you're right they do
stuff like that you gotta be careful
yeah
ascension millennium the greatest thing
that you did I think that defines the
Corey's angels era for sure it's one of
them go for it was pretty defining to
listen we were very grateful for the
hits that we got and em is my favorite
thing I like it so much that we're
having a perfectly grand conversation
here and I had to shoehorn right exactly
let you walk in this room the bottom
line is you didn't have it playing on
marathon I'm very grateful and lucky
that you know midway through my life I
actually finally you know scored a hit
or two on an album because I'd only done
six and I think it's about time somebody
lists
but you know hey you never know I could
have done ten and nobody listened so I'm
very grateful for it and we were we were
at Keven Undergaro
birthday party Maria Menounos his
husband yes when you were there and he
insisted on singing leave like five
minutes after we did and it was like 10
minutes after I walked in and I was like
bright red and I was like thank you
that's really sweet gotta go yeah
they are wonderful people they're very
nice yeah yeah well I hope this thing
comes out because here on this show
we've well I mean we we've we calmed
through all the r.kelly
the whole mini series we comb through
the whole Finding Neverland land I hope
you'll be combing through truth the rape
of two Coreys very soon a hundred yeah
yes I mean I'm glad that all this stuff
is finally finally like seeing the light
it has to ever all it has stories
they're kind of you've heard whispers
forever and it's like that's probably
not real it's probably not real because
we don't want to believe it's real
because it's just we're fine yeah to
imagine that people would actually turn
the other way when this [ __ ] is going on
for kids that's right you just don't
want to believe that people are that
sick
and watch marriage boot camp that's
right because otherwise the producers of
we TV are gonna kill me
it starts out I guess it's like Cory's
been said in the interview with Fox he's
like I don't even know if the show is
gonna be good I don't know if it's gonna
be respectful I hope it's good I do well
you know look I've done reality shows
before okay and out of the three that
I've done one of them I produced and it
went off great the other two I didn't
produce and I got screwed so all I'm
saying is I don't know what they're
gonna do in the end but we're gonna hope
because this is a therapeutic show that
they're gonna handle things respectfully
and they're gonna understand that these
are some very serious topics we're
dealing with we're talking about child
abuse we're talking about sex abuse
Aaron Carter as everybody knows is kind
of a mess right now and we don't want to
send them off the rails any more than he
already is we also don't want to send me
or my brother or any you know it's it's
volatile situations that could
definitely erode
very quickly if they're not handled
properly right yes so that's all I'm
saying is hopefully they handle it
respectfully and they don't do the
cheesy you know surreal life version of
reality shows because if they do there
could be some very very negative
backlash so I'm putting my faith in the
producers and the people at we TV to
produce a healthy therapeutic positive
outlook on how we're trying to make our
lives better well and if that's what it
is hey hallelujah we'll all be happy
right one more Jim and Sam catch up with
full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM app